i like how republicans have painted
themselves into a corner by labeling
anything to do with
intelligence as liberal so anytime they
make a smart decision
they're losing politically why don't you
learn science
and challenge us scientifically with
intelligence and not just because of
your gut
feeling or something and they're like
but then i would have to get
smart and change who i am
to challenge you and i shouldn't have to
change who i am
by becoming smarter you're working to
make your boss
more money and to pay for his house
i'm working on building my own [ __ ]
house
because that's what labor is for not
for the exploitation but for actual
tangible benefits and results in the
middle you have this
lush green atmosphere full of tropical
geckos and
robertson salamanders
the reddish hue comes from the
magnesium in the soil that is
exposed to oxygen through the fissures
and they produce photonic
beams
and die that make themselves
a little reddish hue and
it uh they
makes itself red and then these plants
they eat that and then they turn red
themselves
so it's the whole balance of red in this
ionosphere
crazy i gotta go down there i gotta
check this out
check check check it out people will go
into
the country in the wilderness
and they'll apply their own flag here
it's like
on in america and i claimed this for
america
it was already america the whole time i
guess they feel
still feeling outsiders
in their own country not at home in my
own country
some cowboy and indian [ __ ] kicking in
they're like this is mine but then why
are there so many savages here
trying to kill me their tracks where
they disturbed
the formation of these beautiful plates
it's like you run into this thing and it
turns into a billion pieces
oh my god they ran through the plants
right here
man that's so destructive yeah
camping
with americans in the background
i'm glad they decided to park right by
me some people
come to the desert and the wilderness
for peace and quiet
and other people come to ruin the peace
and quiet
and to express themselves and to be as
loud as they want without anyone
complaining
these two people have to camp at the
same campsite so
i mean what are you gonna do this is how
you make a fire
you make a little cube with bigs
on bottom and small on top
and then you light up the kindling at
the top which is the smallest stuff
and then you get the fire as it works
its way down
just create a cube and all the heat will
be contained inside and
the wood will burn and stuff
rocking out with the noise here camping